alors en ce moment je reçois beaucoup de
demandes de tests de produits de trucs
un peu bizarres généralement je suis un
peu sceptique sur ce que je reçois ou
sur ce qu'on me propose
là j'avoue j'étais hyper sceptique sur
ce dont on va parler aujourd'hui ce
petit truc là j'étais hyper sceptique
mais
[Musique]
salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique moi encore je
suis ravie comme toujours de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ailleurs si vous aimez la vidéo la
création de vidéos si vous aimez les
tutos le test de matos tout ça et bien
vous pouvez envisager de cliquer sur le
petit bouton s'abonner qui se situe
juste en dessous activer la cloche pour
être notifiée tout ça tout ça mais vous
avez maintenant l'habitude alors
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un accessoire
dont j'avais pas mal entendu parler
j'avais vu des tests et tout et puis je
me disais est ce que vraiment est ce que
vraiment c'est utile et donc la marque
look des cas proposé de m'envoyer un de
ces petits bijoux ici là d'ailleurs il
sponsorise cette vidéo mais bien
évidemment je donnerais mon avis
totalement objectif est vraiment je vous
dirai ce que j'en pense pas parce qu'il
sponsorise la vidéo que je dirais des
trucs que je pense pas ça fait
maintenant un peu plus d'un mois que je
teste et que je fais des montages sur
cette bête là et je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui ce que j'en pense que vous
spoiler un petit peu c'est plutôt pas
mal
je vais vous expliquer exactement à quoi
ça sert comment l'utilisent ici dans
final cut
même si ça marche avec beaucoup d'autres
choses et je pas résisté j'ai fait un
peu de bémol donc juste pour vous
montrer un petit peu à quoi ça ressemble
birol
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
que tu fais moi
m
alors loupe d'aix c'est quoi c'est une
mini console en fait de montages comme
on peut voir sur des grosses stations
des fois des grosses console là c'est
une version hyper compact qui a pour but
de venir accompagner la souris le
trackpad et le clavier bien que vous
allez voir que moi du coup le clavier
ben je m'en sers beaucoup moins puisque
le youdec fait vraiment du très très bon
taf
ça fonctionne avec première final cut
lightroom et plein d'autres logiciels
que vous pouvez voir sur le site de
l'ouzbek et puis pour ceux qui sont pas
supporter de base bien vous avez tout à
fait la possibilité de créer tous vos
raccourcis vous même parce que vous
allez voir c'est entièrement
paramétrable entièrement customisable
d'ailleurs nous on va le tester sur
final cut mais vous pouvez aller voir la
vidéo que mon pote charles a fait il a
testé sur premières et sur lightroom
c'est vraiment sympa aussi quand on
reçoit un look dec voilà ce qu'on trouve
dans la boîte déjà on a un packaging qui
est hyper très bien de qui est vraiment
hyper bien foutu c'est beau c'est joli
on a vraiment une sensation de premium
canton nous via pas grand chose dans la
boîte à hormis le look dès qu il ya
également un petit peu de ne pas placer
un petit peu de papier de nautisme et
qui a pas spécialement besoin de lire un
on a le câble usb c'est puisqu'il se
branche sur un port usb sait et c'est à
peu près tout comment ça se présente
ici bas on a tout un tas de pottas ici
qu'on va pouvoir assigner qu'on peut
donc tourné dès qu'on peut aussi
appliquer quand tout simplement il ya
plein de choses à faire ils sont
cliquables
vous allez voir après on va faire un
test je vais vous montrer exactement à
quoi ça sert on a une énorme boulette
ici qu'est très très agréable au toucher
vraiment la sensation quand même de
produits premium
on a tout un tas de touche ici donc si
on a l'équivalent des flèches
on a un petit ndoole qui nous évite de
te taper le petit commentaire
quand il ya une erreur c'est sûr foyer
lequel on s'en fout un peu
il ya ici six boutons là aussi qu'ils
sont paramétrables qui permettent ici de
faire des équivalents de touches du
clavier et on a un écran tactile sur
lequel on peut swype et on peut toucher
et tous ses boutons
ici ils sont complètement paramétrable
c'est à dire que là j'ai des choses que
j'ai faites moi on a une petite
vibration quand on touche à une touche
pour nous signifier que l'action a bien
été faite et grosso modo voilà comment
ça se présente
l'interface du logiciel ici se présente
comme ça tout simplement on va pouvoir
les chercher des actions ici les les
listes et des délais raccourcis et si je
veux supprimer un réglage hop je le fais
glisser et un jeu les plus il est sorti
je vais me rajouter ici le raccourci
pour pouvoir faire un cut
là où se trouve ma tête de lecture up et
voilà j'ai mon raccourci qui rajoute et
ici tout simplement c'est pas plus
compliqué on va pouvoir a signé aussi
des choses aux boutons qui sont là en
cliquant dessus on voit qu'ici il ya
tout ce qu'il nous faut c'est plutôt
cool et moi je me suis fait donc mes
réglages custom vraiment c'est hyper
simple à appréhender déjà à paramétrer
c'est vraiment simple et en plus de ça à
utiliser vous allez voir on va faire un
petit test
c'est hyper simple possible alors vous
avez vu moi je place le groupe tec sur
la main gauche comme ça j'ai la main
gauche qui va être soit sur la souris
soit sur le trackpad est en avance c'est
parti on y va on y va
alors je me déplace déjà avec mon
trackpad normalement déjà vous pouvez
voir que quand je me mets d'en faire une
queue qui se met automatiquement sur les
réglages de fine que tu y détecte le
logiciel qui est ouvert et il va se
mettre en fonction sur le profil que
j'ai créée pour final cut si j'ouvre le
rite romain
il va se mettre sur le profil lightroom
alors déjà avec la molette je pouvais me
déplacer frame par frame pour pouvoir un
petit peu être précis dans ce que je
fais le reste du temps je peux me
déplacer avec
manon trackpad c'est vrai que la molette
pour la précision va aider beaucoup si
je veux faire mon des roches
je vais me mettre sur mon plan je vais
le sélectionner je vais cliquer sur la
touche 4 que j'ai défini comme la touche
qui sert pour mes points d'entrée
ensuite je vais aller jusqu ici on va
dire et je vais faire un touche 5
c'est mon point de sortie et ensuite la
touche 6 pour que cette partie de mon
plan soit en favori je peux refaire la
même chose ici alors là j'ai déjà
sélectionné une partie mais on va le
refaire donc entrées sorties favori
jusque là on est cool c'est très bien je
vais aller mettre mes plans dans ma
timeline ici est celui ci ce que j'ai
sélectionné en favori et maintenant je
vais pouvoir utiliser ce potard ici pour
zoomer ma timeline pour avoir plus d
espace si je clique dessus j'ai défini
pour avoir l'intégralité de ma timeline
qui rentre dans l'écran mais ici je n'ai
pas besoin côte au sud on va faire comme
ça j'ai défini ici le raccourci que j'ai
montré tout à l'heure pour que tu es
sélectionné supprimés voilà ça va aussi
vite que ça je peux ensuite allé
chercher les outils ici je retrouve tous
mes outils si je veux par exemple
l'outil sélection pour prendre une
partie ici et la supprimer j'ai tous mes
outils ici qui sont qui sont calés je
vais revenir sur mon pointer si je veut
redimensionner ici mon image je faire
ainsi je veux faire un zoom up
automatiquement il m'affiche la fonction
de redimensionnement
en fait j'avais peur que ayant tellement
l'habitude de mes raccourcis clavier je
perde du temps mais après quelques
heures d'utilisation
c'est devenu aussi intuitif que si
j'utilisais mais raccourcis clavier et
on va gagner quelques clics ans ça va ça
va pas être un temps monstrueux de
gagner mais aussi certaines actions où
il y avait deux boutons ou deux clics à
faire eh ben on va pouvoir les faire en
un seul clic et quand on fait du montage
toute la journée quand on fait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup
montage ces cliques qui sont assez
précieux parce que bas à la fin de la
journée à la fin du mois ça fait du
temps de gagné
et puis c'est très très agréable à
utiliser il ya un côté voilà tactile où
on touche les choses on bouge
le zoom les choses comme ça les potards
moi j'aime beaucoup cette approche là et
c'est vraiment très très très agréable
alors ici on est dans l'espace 1 c'est
l'espace qui sert pour tout ce qui est
montage pour tout ce qui est outil mais
on va pouvoir switcher avec le 2 et le 3
si j'appuie ici sur le 2 je passe sur la
partie colorimétrie alors ici vous avez
vu que tout a changé et directement la
température de mon plan avec ici ce
potard voyez que ça fait ça fait bouger
en fait le curseur de la température de
la teinte également et donc je vais
aller sur mes routes couleurs ici et je
vais pouvoir aller là ici avec l'écran
tactile déplacer la couleur de mon
master je peux augmenter plus ou moins
l'exposition générale je peux aller sur
les ombres ici avec les potards je vais
pouvoir gérer ici la saturation ici
l'exposition de mes ombres
pareil pour les midterms
je vais pouvoir plus ou moins les
exposer et si je fais un petit peu
n'importe quoi pour vous montrer un mais
pareil pour les hautes lumières on peut
monter descendre mais là pour le coup
moi je vais retourner sur mes ombres ici
et là on va les baisser un petit peu et
on a quelque chose qui me plaît à peu
près donc là on est sur toute la partie
écolo
je ne sais pas si cette partie là c'est
la partie que j'apprécie le plus
moi je suis vraiment plus sur la partie
montage j'ai un petit peu mes habitudes
sur mes roues de couleurs avec le
clavier la souris fin le trackpad en
l'occurrence mai mais je pense que ça
avec le temps c'est quelque chose que je
pourrais franchement apprécié si je vais
sur l'espace 3 maintenant alors là pour
le coup on va juste récupérer un peu de
son qu'on va mettre là si je vais sur
l'espace 3 je passe sur la partie sont
alors honnêtement moi je vais pas m'en
servir énormément de cette partie là
pour le volume c'est pas mal parce que
je peux gérer le volume comme ça
directement bon ça reste pas un grand
gain mais je peux aussi passé sur la
partie outils sélection en cliquant ici
et pouvoir sélectionner seulement un
goût le bc un petit peu ça c'est plutôt
chouette et repartir sur mon pointer ça
c'est plutôt pas mal j'avoue c'est la
partie que j'aime bien
on peut ajouter des qui frame on peut
ajouter des transitions
bref on peut zoomer on peut gérer la
hauteur également avec ceux potard de
nos formes d'onde pour pouvoir un petit
peu voir ce qui se passe et encore je
pense que je suis pas allé complètement
jusqu'au bout de ce qu'on peut faire
avec ce look d'aig parce que on peut
aller jusqu'à créer des macros créer des
actions assez balèze ça c'est pas un
truc pour l'instant que danger l'utilité
mais si vous voulez dans un bel utilité
c'est carrément carrément intéressant
pour tout vous dire moi ce truc là j'en
suis tombé totalement amoureux je suis
encore capable de monter avec juste mon
clavier mon trackpad quand je suis en
déplacement je n'ai peut-être pas le
trimballer pour faire du montage de la
volée mais par contre quand je suis
tranquille chez moi sur nos stations de
montage j'avoue ce truc là c'est un
régal il ya ce côté pratique d'avoir
tout accessible ici d'un simple clic et
tous les outils qu'on utilise au
quotidien rapidement sans avoir à faire
des raccourcis clavier il ya aussi ce
côté vraiment analogique de d'avoir des
boutons de pouvoir tourner des molettes
de pouvoir tourner des pot'arts que moi
j'aime vraiment beaucoup le seul truc
négatif parce qu on sait que pour
l'utiliser il va falloir passer le
clavier en mode us en mode amérique
donc ça veut dire que quand on veut
taper du texte parce que pour taper un
titre par exemple il faut switcher entre
le clavier américain et le clavier
français et ça c'est juste un petit peu
un petit peu relou penser juste à
l'activé ces 2 clics
en début de session et pour les titres
c'est un peu chiant je pense que là
dessus nous dès qu'ils pourraient nous
faire les raccourcis
du des claviers français ou d autres d
autres pays d autres claviers parce que
c'est juste ça qui est un tout petit peu
relou ça change pas l'utilisation
générale mais voilà je te dis quand même
à dire il ya ce tout petit point négatif
c'est le seul que j'ai vu à
l'utilisation du loup québec
si vous voulez plus d'infos sur le loup
dès que je vous mets des liens en
descriptions que vous pouvez aller voir
pouvez vous renseigner c'est ça coûte
dans les 500 euros à peu près
franchement je pense que ça les vaut
puis voilà si cette vidéo vous a plu les
amis n'hésitez pas à mettre le
traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de vidéos aller voir d'autres
vidéos sur final cut
il y en a plein plein plein la dernière
que j'ai fait c'est plein d'astuces
aussi que vous pouvez aller voir sur
final cut bref les amis je vous dis
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo